[Música]
son las 4 de la mañana del 27 de
diciembre del 2019
mi celular suena
por mi mente pasa una idea
que no quisiera escuchar en esa llamada
y en efecto
se trataba a la amada
de la agencia de alarmas diciendo que el
emprendimiento
el local donde tenemos nuestro
había sido saqueado
había entrado un ladrón por la madrugada
y había repetido lo mismo que hace 15
días habíamos pasado
en aquella primera ocasión
el aviso no fue de la central de alarmas
sino de una amiga
el mensaje era muy claro amigo ven
rápido se llevaron todo qué impotencia
qué coraje
al llegar al lugar
dónde
tengo el emprendimiento y ver cristales
rotos una tienda revuelta
me doy cuenta que en efecto se llevaron
casi todo
casi todo un año de trabajo
donde lo único que hicimos
nuestro equipo y yo fue reinvertir todo
lo que íbamos vendiendo para hacer
crecer poco a poco
ese pequeño negocio al que yo le llamo
mi sueño
sinceramente cuando me dispuse a
emprender
siendo a un empleado sabía que los retos
eran grandes pero nunca me imaginé que
tanto
entonces ahí es donde comprendí que el
primer paso para querer ser emprendedor
es estar loco
alguien de aquí es o quieres ser
emprendedor por favor podría levantar la
mano
muy bien no no no no no no
podrían ponerse de pie
les dije que no bajarán las más
porque guau qué padre
podrían poner esa mano en su cabeza
flexionar un poco las rodillas
ya y empezar a caminar orangutanes es en
serio vamos
saben cómo lo hacen los orangutanes
pueden hacer los sonidos oigan son mi
manada de ley de ley es en serio y
fuerte fue escuches en martillo vamos
ah
muchas gracias
yo sé yo sé que han de estar diciendo
eric qué tiene que ver esto con
emprender bueno esto es lo mínimo que
van a tener que hacer si se quieren
aventar el camino del emprendimiento
ya están si se pararon si lo hicieron
delante de las demás personas ya están
en el camino correcto así que un aplauso
para ustedes por favor
[Aplausos]
si vamos a tener que hacer eso y más
pero estoy convencido que antes de
emprender tenemos que trabajar en
nosotros mismos y eso es light es la
idea que vengo a compartirles el día de
hoy porque porque noto
que cuando queremos aprender un poquito
sobre emprendimiento y tener una ética
se habla muy poco de este tema de la
persona
hay talleres
hay diplomados incluso estoy en uno de
ellos hay universidades que tienen
carreras completas para enseñarte a
emprender
pero será suficiente tener solo solo
esas herramientas será suficiente querer
será suficiente el decir si me traigo un
producto de alta demanda para empezar mi
propio negocio si vamos a innovar este
servicio y resolver ese problema vamos a
levantar capital vamos a trabajar duro y
así empieza a crecer una empresa
creo que no es suficiente creo que
primero está la persona
ese loco que se aventó ese camino
que muchos queremos recorrer pero pocos
estamos dispuestos a pagar el precio
y es lo que les quiero platicar hoy si
no trabajamos en nosotros mismos primero
difícilmente vamos a poder
enfrentar todas esas adversidades que
nos vamos a encontrar como emprendedores
cuáles muchísimas inseguridad díganmelo
a mí
qué más falta de recursos para operar
día a día un negocio una competencia muy
agresiva monopolios que casi no existen
verdad
y incluso cosas más sencillas que tienen
que ver con el factor humano como el
querer atraer a tu negocio talento
también ahí hay una crisis
el querer involucrar más gente en
nuestro emprendimiento o problemas de
factor tiempo como me sucede a mí que
por un lado estás emprendiendo y por el
otro sigue siendo empleado de una
empresa
ahí el problema es que nuestro tiempo se
limita
y cuando ya estás emprendiendo y
empiezan estas adversidades te empiezas
a saturar empieza a caminar terrenos en
los cuales no tenías experiencia y es
donde tu estabilidad emocional puede
tambalear
y
a veces se nos olvida que todas nuestras
creaciones todos nuestros proyectos
están ligados a nosotros
si nosotros no estamos bien ellos no lo
van a estar
el otro día un amigo se acercó conmigo y
me decía
eric tengo una idea ya sé que quiero
hacer es un emprendimiento padrísimo me
lo platicó a grandes rasgos y me
pregunta cuál crees tú sé que sería el
primer paso para iniciar esto
y le dije ve al psicólogo
what
no me estás entendiendo y yo vine para
que me dieras un consejo para iniciar mi
negocio no para que me ayudara a
resolver mis problemas personales
exacto le dije viste en el clavo si no
resuelve sus problemas personales
difícilmente vas a poner esas bases en
este proyecto personal difícilmente vas
a estar fuerte para iniciar entonces el
psicólogo es si o si
incluso si no lo quieres asegurarte
porque tú te sientes súper zen y crees
que toda tu vida es maravillosa el día 1
que empieza a emprender a la semana lo
vas a ocupar te lo firme
ok se sacó un poco de onda y me dice
supongamos que ya fui al psicólogo que
otra que otra recomendación me darías
para emprender
cómprate una agenda
mi hijo a ver eric ya estás mal
estamos en el 2020 aquí tengo todo
cómprate una agenda
no solamente es para agendar actividades
cómprate una agenda y escribe todo lo
que quieras hacer con ese proyecto
escribe todo lo que quieras que suceda
con tu emprendimiento
escríbelo incluso como si ya estuviera
sucediendo así en presente plasma todo
lo que soñaste
cuántas sucursales quieres tener en qué
ciudades que estás viendo qué montos
estás vendiendo que el número de
personas tiene tu equipo todo lo más
detallado posible
ahora sí ya que los plasmas te de manera
presente estamos escribiendo el futuro
de ahí lo vamos a arrastrar hacia atrás
y vamos a ir poniendo puntualmente que
necesito hacer para llegar hasta ese
punto
es una manera muy diferente de planear
tu proyecto estamos acostumbrados a
hacerlo día 1 tal cosa día 2 tal no no
no que quiero porque porque ya te lo
estás imaginando tú ya lo estás creando
ya lo tienes en la mente plasmarlo es
por eso que es tan importante en la
agenda te va a ayudar a visualizar
y la visualización es una de las
herramientas más importantes más
importantes para todos los que queremos
crear cosas extraordinarias
entonces la agencia la agenda te va a
servir una para ese ejercicio de
visualización y dos para que tengas una
estructura para que tengas un camino a
seguir es muy difícil subirte al barco
sin saber a dónde quieres llegar
entonces ese fue mi segundo consejo
cómprate una agenda
me dice 'me 4 y esa es que eric yo venía
por otro tipo de consejos esto no me lo
esperaba pero están buenos
no lo había pensado dije claro
muchas veces si no es que la mayoría
volteamos a vernos nosotros primero
queremos emprender queremos alentar nos
y no hemos limpiado la casa aún
entonces me dice ok cuál sería un tercer
y un último consejo que me darías
y mi respuesta fue sana tu relación con
mamá y papá
ahí palideció
y lo peor es que yo me puse más pálido
cuando me respondió
mi hija de eric una no tengo papá y dos
la relación con mi mamá apenas si es
buena
amigo tienes que sanar la relación con
mamá y papá no me estoy refiriendo a una
relación social sino una relación
emocional estés o no estés con ellos
esas dos relaciones son la base de
nuestra vida
esto no está bien difícilmente todo lo
demás lo va a estar
tienes que regresar les toda esa carga
que has venido llevando desde niño
incluso si no los tienes o no estás con
ellos hace una carta
donde le entregas a tus padres todo eso
que vienes cargando
detalla la agradece les honra los
independientemente quiénes fueron
desde un parque a un bosque a un lugar
lindo y qué mala
el fuego es el único elemento que
transforma
qué mala
los humanos aprendemos por símbolos
y esa acción simbólicamente te va a
ayudar mucho a sanar
y te va a ayudar a empezar con bases
bien firmes entonces sana tu relación
con mamá y papá
así como a ese amigo que compartía estos
tres consejos y hoy se los comparto a
ustedes
no lo hago porque a mí en lo personal me
insistió mucho en ese momento en el que
llegue a mi negocio y vi que se habían
robado casi todo
en esta ocasión parte de mi equipo me
preguntó
eric
y ahora qué vamos a hacer mi respuesta
fue empezar de nuevo
podrán habernos robado muchas cosas
materiales pero nunca nunca nuestros
sueños
muchas gracias soy eric puente
[Música]
sí
e